vous allez voir des giroflées des
murailles une fleur comme vous n'en avez
jamais vu
wayne n'était pas du tout sur la bonne
route de recherche parce que tu vas
retrouver l'équipe
il est un message du bureau de la
défense civile des états unis d'amérique
au chili sont une attaque
c'est moche que cela cesse ma peine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi je suis les héros par les héros mais
chez vous aidez-nous
il faut qu'on trouve des armes il en y
passent par ta faute je vais t'en
vouloir à mort qu'est-ce que tu suggères
jeudi qu'il pour les attirer par côté du
bâtiment et nous barrer de l'autre
je suis un magicien niveau 20 à donjons
et dragons qui nous protègera
[Musique]
vous autres les asociaux pourquoi vous
dit pelé son big on n'est pas dans une
[ __ ] des dégâts ok
tu sais combien elles m'ont coûté
[Musique]
est-ce qu'il est mort évidemment qu'il
est mort ryan il vient de tomber c'est
une fois
qu'il nous faut c'est du temps
t'es sérieux là
la sauce
[Musique]
j'avais l'air d'un idiot plus tôt tu ne
pas battre